air pollution is bad for you and we know
that exercise is good for you but
there's this on answered question of is
exercising in close proximity to traffic
enough of a bad thing for you that we
should be recommending separating biking
lanes from traffic altogether
the challenge with biking in the city is
that bikers are breathing heavily in the
zone where exhaust is being emitted by
motor vehicles and although motor
vehicles have become cleaner over the
last 20 or 30 years they're still not as
clean as they need to be especially when
you put people that are exercising right
in the close proximity of the exhaust
the primary goal of the study is to
develop and deploy new ways of measuring
air pollution what we're doing is
majoring both the concentrations of
pollution that people encounter as they
move around the city and we're also
measuring people's respiration rates so
the liters per minute of air that
they're breathing in and when you
multiply those two things together unit
the dose we have five things with people
where so they wear a shirt that measures
their minute ventilation and it measures
their heart rate including their heart
rate variability so the timing of the
beats and then we ask them to wear to
air pollution monitors and then we ask
them to wear a blood pressure monitor
that automatically picks a measurement
every half hour and then finally during
the ride we ask them to log their
location using a GPS device we have two
years to work out all the bugs and prove
that we can make all the measurements
that we need to make then and only then
would we get the green light to go on
and do the larger health study we know
from a lot of other previous studies
that breathing the tiny little particles
that are in the
by motor vehicles especially diesel
vehicles our concern because of the fact
that those tiny particles get deep into
our lungs and they can even be absorbed
into our bloodstream and cause health
effects in various parts of our body
including over the long term if you're
exposed you know for many years to the
development of cardiovascular disease of
the kind that we see with cigarette
smoking our goal is to have a phone app
that kind of looks like a Google map
that would optimize route that minimizes
exposure yeah but also trading up
against the time that it would take to
follow that route so that a person could
choose some balance between saving time
and saving air pollution exposure
there's nothing else that I found it
makes me as excited as I am to do this
you can't ride roller coasters to give
you this feeling you can't do other
places and see anything like this this
is unique to here